- La Vallée des rois,
nécropole des dignitaires
et des pharaons, et parmi eux,
le plus grququque l'Égypte
ait jamais connu, Toutankhamon,
le pharaon au masque d'or.
Il y a 100 ans, la première
marche menant à son tombeau
a dédédécouverte par
l'archéologue Howard Carter,
financé par l'égyptologue
et philanthrope Lord Carnarvon.
Après des années de fouilles
et des tonnes de gravats
déplacées, un des rois les plus
mystérieux, le 11e pharaon de
la 18e dynastie, livrait enfin
une partie de ses secrets.
Dre PERRINE POIRON, docteure
égyptologie, UQAM et Sorbonne
- Il est évident qu'avec
ses 5000... ses quelque
5300 objets qui ont pris
presque une dizaine d'années
à recenser, c'était... c'est
le plus gros trésor funéraire
qu'on ait mis au jour dans
l'histoire pharaonique.
Donc c'est c'est de l'or,
de l'argent, de l'ébène,
de l'ivoire, des objets,
des meubles.
- Un trésor inestimable,
un arrêt sur images de la vie
quotidienne des Égyptiens
du Nouvel Empire.
- Vous savez, tous ces collierss
sur les fresques, bien là,
le corps de Toutankhamon on
en est orné; on a ses bouquets
de fleurs. Donc pour l'histoire
de la botanique, par exemple,
ça a été une excellente avancée.
On a de l'alimentation, donc
par exemple égalemenavavavoir
comment les anciens Égyptiens
se nourrissaient.
- Une véritable "Toutan-mania"
s'empare de la planète.
Le jeune pharaon est le fils de
la reine Néfertiti à la beauté
légendaire et du roi Akhenaton,
qui avait réformé le culte en
Égypte.
- On l'appelle le roi enfant.
Donc en effet, il est... il a
été porté donc sur le trône à
l'âge de 9 ans, on suppose vers
l'âge de 9 ans. Et donc, selon
les analyses de sa momie, il
serait décédé au d d de l'âge
de 19 ans.
- Mort jeune, sans descendance,
ce sera son d-d-d-père qui lui
succèdera. Un siècle après
cette découverte majeure,
le trédududu tombeau de
Toutânkhamon continue de
révéler ses secrets.
isisis saviez-vous que ce trésor
n'est pas le sien, en grande
majorité, et qu'à l'origine,il ?
Donc ça a été prouvé on a
les noms de cette femme qui a
été... donc elle s'appelait
Néfernéferouaton, cette reine
pharaon qui a été effacée
de l'histoire.
- Entre la légende de
ce roi important de l'Égypte
pharaonique et les mystères
qui l'entourent, la croyance
populaire s'est vite emparée
de Tnknknkhamon, donnant
même naissance au mythe de
la malédiction de la momie.
Ici, Yasmine Khayat, R R Radioa